how I come to this video a bit later I
had to started this recording who is
something wrong parameter so I needed to
restart it okay um what do we have here
blue thought yeah okay Bishop g7 now man
I tried this age for line a couple of
times I always feel tempted to do that
let's let's see what happens it seems
that c6 is regarded assume being the
best move at the moment but now this
this sharp approach is certainly am a
bit more good for goon fell dish if you
if you can use this strange word okay
let's see he probably will take at some
point but not now yeah i have e 5 here
available Justin
maybe
I'm not not so sure I mean at one point
you might attack this Bishop I'd like to
give it a square on a jewel-like 97 be
six or if I go e 597 he always has an IP
6 on 95 maybe this is a luxury I cannot
really afford but ok let's let's see
it's a very strange position anyway I'm
not quite sure what black so players
here if I've maybe now but then i can
just go D Drive problem you know so
defined for or should I take only five
you know d takes d5 assume a more solid
approach I don't know d hi would look
strange with the bishop on c4 as well no
this is this i didn't expect and
interesting i was only considering a
bishop f3 of course uh-huh so i can I
could play b6 here is good I don't know
did the capture queen bee three or just
Bishop e2 and I can't keep it simple
this should be should be a pain u6 also
maybe maybe more aggressive but how to
hard to decide yeah now he probably will
take only five
now I can play will create a fav insists
you can do that after that maybe maybe I
go is 60
could we need seven I've got 95 if this
does not make much sense okay so I just
let's just trade here and check
and if I go of a tick on c6 isn't this
here 9650 197 check King h8 it may be
trapped down it's may be trapped 7
shaking edge 891 he must place his six
I've got h5 it's not it's not the one
hundred percent clear maybe okay I need
to just play this position it it seems
like a slightly better and game for
white because of the King in the center
I should have played this quicker I mean
going for this end game it's a it's it's
clearly okay for me and didn't it didn't
really help to consider this night c67
it's probably not working anyway okay 95
yeah I guess
III is a good spot for the light to
cover c4 especially
yeah I'd like to go F for Night Moves
Bishop g7 at night see for this is a
good plan so can i play a 4 here or well
maybe that's some tactic with knigu
tortious here it's a not not very urgent
all this we can I can easily prepare
things for here gets an autumn but 93
adds was a bit sloppy okay yeah maybe
this wasn't so so precise yeah it should
be okay for black I probably shouldn't
have taken the rooks off okay time
worrying what can you do
yeah i know i have set 93 but i need to
convert you for I guess check
okay let's let's see
check check check check check
I g4 I lost it was too slow he's got a
piece gotta pass porn but it does not
matter really remained in the king and
porn and game it's not a problem check
yeah this is just a win now check
checkmate Jim now I don't know this end
game I mean you shouldn't I shouldn't
really win it but I guess he played them
some some bad moves though not so let's
let's let's start to slide around here I
would like to first time I must quickly
check that 96 yeah the computer computer
likes it but I wasn't checked I was of
course referring to this computer or
cetera all night and no assault c6 and I
thought it it is stripped but I have
Bishop c5 this is what I forgot about
hmm this is what oh this is the point
yeah then 96 is of course grade i
calculated this far h5 threatening to
take and then I thought okay he attacks
it and it is trapped out Bishop g5 this
is what I saw and it's it's leading to
nowhere but I can go here of course and
this is this is an HEC good I mean it's
a it's still not needs to be calculated
but this is winning
this is a winning for white check check
yeah but this is something that the
Blitz game is quite tough night f5 with
a winning attack computer gives plus 20
to 22 okay okay some of this was
basically winning the game but I know no
way to do that I mean I had a hunch that
it was working but what what can you do
okay I took here and now we had this
this end game this end game type of
position yeah computer wants to go 97
check and h5 yeah it is simply a matter
of tactics that is tough to calculate I
wanted to go here anyway and here this
is probably a bit lame this was my
original intention but then I sort of I
don't know I had some some some some bad
feelings above the king only two opposed
to the rook maybe I still should do that
something like that yeah this is maybe a
little something for white but not
nothing substantial okay yeah and here i
am i am a bit better but it's it's
really it's really not not much come all
of a bit of bit more space matter of
course it is said wrong you should
change or electively easily but
so somewhere somewhere here was
regrouping to see Frank check check it's
just probably solely still okay and and
I don't know it it's already it's a bit
tricky I get to see four and the passer
is not it's not worth much I here here I
could have played g4 maybe I should have
thought about this a bit longer but ok
26 seconds yeah this is this is
interesting on that age five tried to to
get a pass on him maybe a good idea ok
this happened and now of course this was
sloppy I could have exchanged of course
this is this is straight with straight
straight away winning and now a five or
King b3 is probably both winning Kingda
3c for this is basically the game this
is basically the game and here he could
could avoid wipe the trade I mean this
is probably also win but it's Jack yeah
this so this was clearly a win but he's
he's in a can of zoosk one what what are
you doing here can go here and then I'm
switching oops no yeah switching back to
to this and get a five yeah this was
interesting alright thanks for watching